hello everyone and welcome to an amazing
game that was played on board four of
round two of this year's fed Grand Swiss
the Serbian Grandmaster Alexander p with
the wi pieces against polish Grandmaster
Yang shishto Duda uh let's check it out
a beautiful attacking game you guys will
enjoy it uh so Pawn to D4 by Alexander
for his first move we have Knight to F6
Pawn to C4 E6 we have Knight to F3 and
pawn to D5 transposing into the Queen's
Gambit decline we have Knight to C3 uh
the three Knights variation and there
are many uh great continuations here for
black here you could go for the for the
semi slav defense you could go for the
semi tarash you could go for the ragozin
with Bishop to B4 you could go for the
barman defense with Knight be to D7 but
uh Duda goes for D captures on C4 it is
the Viana variation and it is um if you
guys are interested the sixth most
popular continuation for black uh as of
uh today we have Pawn to E4 grabbing the
full Center as black abandoned abandoned
it by playing d captures on C4 and now
Bishop um uh to B4 continuing
development pinning that Knight and now
threatening Knight captures on e4 so
okay Bishop captures on C4 and now
Knight captures on e4 we have castles
trying to give up the C3 uh Knight and
then the pawn as well H but Duda
actually goes Knight back to F6 and
these are the three most popular moves
here Knight captures on C3 Bishop
captures on C3 and also Knight back to
F6 just to give you an example of what
happens um uh well it's very dangerous
to take the pawn okay you take it let's
say Rook B1 and now you would really
like to Castle and enjoy your extra
material but if you do that then comes
Queen D3 attacks the bishop and once the
bishop moves then comes Knight G5
Checkmate is being threatened only way
to defend is G6 and then comes Queen H3
again Checkmate is being threatened and
okay you play H5 but now Pawn to G4 and
the black's Position will very quickly
open up even if you throw in a nice E5
preventing G captures on H5
uh White will simply take the pawn uh so
it's not really an issue and if Bishop
captures on G sorry if Bishop captures
on G4 Queen to E3 and white is just much
much better here there is no stopping E6
and um white wins this game wins this
game very quickly so instead after
castles uh well you could play uh the
the double capture it's very complicated
to play it afterwards so Knight back to
F6 uh and now uh it's again a very
popular uh position Queen to A4 for
example in 2019 mag Carlson played
against Fabiano corana in the singfield
cup their game ended in a draw and queen
to A4 is by far the most popular
continuation and some other
continuations are popular like Bishop to
G5 but here uh we have the immediate
Queen to C2 and it is not already as of
move eight that we have a completely new
game so okay let's see how Duda handles
this he castles safety and now Rook to
D1 nicely a defending the pawn aligning
The Rook with the black queen Knight
beat to D7 and now Knight to E5 five
getting the the Knight to a very
important Central Square and usually if
you try to capture uh it's not going to
end all that well for example D captures
now the queen is attacked and once the
Knight moves now the pawn gains all the
control here and black will have very
big problems defending this position the
Knight comes to E4 uh and it's really
bad for black so instead Bishop back to
E7 by Duda uh Rook to D3 uh just
starting out with a nice Rook Li The
Rook can out come to G3 to H3 and
although we sometimes call these moves
sort of barbaric as it's it's very very
obvious what you are trying to do of
course you want to play you know
something like Rook to H3 attack the
Knight capture the Knight and then
Checkmate the black king on H7 uh these
kind of attacks are are very very
effective and it's very difficult to
defend against them even though they are
very obvious uh Knight to B6 attacking
the bishop Bishop back to B3 and now
Knight F to D5 uh we we have Rook to H3
okay threatening Checkmate on H7 and dud
that defends with Pawn to F5 so he does
have to weaken his position a little bit
uh Queen to E2 now Alexander just
continues with his idea he wants to play
Queen H5 followed by Queen captures on
H7 so Queen to E8 stopping that and now
Bishop to D2 and okay Duda says you've
had your fun now it's my turn we have
Pawn to A5 threatening Pawn to A4 so
Pawn to A4 by Alexandra and now B Bishop
to F6 okay the game just nicely
continues Rook to E1 uh Pawn to C6 now
Duda improving his position and now look
at this look at how Alexander continues
the attack Pawn to G4 absolutely
Spectacular Now although it seems like
you probably should be okay capturing
this and opening up D file for your Rook
it would actually be really really bad
because after Queen captures on G4 and
let's say Bishop captures on E5 Rook
captures on E5 and Knight F6 seems like
okay everything is nicely defended H7 is
defended D6 Pawn is defended the Knight
is coming to D5 it's all perfectly fine
uh Queen H4 and now what do you do queen
to E7 or something doesn't really matter
Bishop G5 now threatening the defender
of the H7 pawn and if H6 now you play
Knight to E4 and here you have uh huge
huge problems H captures on G5 if played
then comes Knight captures the F7 point
is defended and there will be no defense
against Queen to h8 Checkmate so you
cannot capture the pawn uh the bishop
with the pawn and if you don't capture
there's really not all that much um you
can do here so while you can play it
it's not going to be great so of course
uh he didn't capture on G4 he played
Bishop captures on E5 and now D captures
on E5 and now just Bishop to D7 again uh
your uh first idea is uh well I'm
getting attacked so why not eliminate as
many pieces as possible you could try
something like Knight captures and B3 B
captures and now F captures and G4 uh
but it's still not going to be enough
even if you get to trade off Queens with
Queen to G6 this is also possible but uh
the position is just so much better for
white uh because uh the uh the
development of the light Square Bishop
is just not very easy to handle and if
you don't develop the light Square
Bishop you can get the Rook into the
game and so on point is that white will
go Bishop C2 Capt on G6 there's really
nothing you can do about that and if
Knight to D5 uh then comes Bishop to G5
and if B5 trying to get the queen
insight to develop somehow you're just
going to play Bishop captures on G6 and
now there is very little you can do
Against The Rook E4 Rook to H4 Rook to
h8 Checkmate or maybe it's not going to
be Checkmate but you will suffer severe
material loss uh there's not not all
that much to play here for black so it
is extremely extremely difficult so
that's why Bishop to D7 G captures on F5
now you cannot uh allow Pawn to F6 so
Rook captures on F5 and now Knight to E4
just bringing another attacker into the
game also maybe some ideas of Knight to
D6 forking the queen and the rook and
while you could play Rook captures on E5
it's basically giving up the exchange
because after Rook to G3 and uh let's
say queen to F7 you will always have
this Knight to F6 check and this will
just um win you The Rook as the G Pawn
is spin so Queen captures Queen captures
and you will uh be be up the exchange so
it's one way to do it and it could be
very well Black's best way of holding
things together but dude that wanted
more he played Queen to E7 and now Queen
to G4 we have Rook captures on E5 and
now Bishop to C2 Shifting the bishop
into the attack as well here on the king
side Knight to C4 attacking the bishop
here and here comes uh well I'm going to
show you what uh uh what Alexander
played he played Bishop to G5 and he
attacked dudas Queen on E7 but there is
one move that is even more powerful and
I'm not even going to ask you to pause
the video because it's just so difficult
to find no no one saw this move uh and
that is Knight to C3 Knight to C3
absolutely spectacular always difficult
to find the move with the Knight back uh
now now you are threatening everything
you're threatening the Knight on C4 also
if the Knight moves The Rook on E5 is
being threatened uh the pawn on H7 is
being threatened and there's just no
good way to handle this if you play Rook
captures then Bishop captures you can no
longer take the uh bishop and again uh
the DF dh7 pawn and the Knight are Hing
and even if you try Knight E5 to attack
the Queen White will first first play
Queen H5 and then you will have to give
up something as now the Knight and pawn
are hanging again and if you play Queen
F6 then you're going to capture on H7
then you're going to play King F1 uh to
avoid any nasty checks and now White's
position is just much much better
theight is coming to
E4 and you're going to uh quickly win
the game however in the game Bishop to
G5 was played and this although it's a
phenomenal move it does allow Duda a
very sneaky move that kind of allows him
to get back into the game I will even
ask you to pause the video and try to
spot this idea as dud that did not play
it in the game so you know while I give
you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on always
looking for cool ways the part with your
queen and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show of course it is Queen
captures on G5 the point point being
that okay if Queen captures you're just
going to take the White Queen and if
Knight captures you take the Rook on E1
as well so uh a knight and a rook for
for a queen and also you will be up to
pawns for example King G2 now you play
H6 you say okay you capture my knight
I'm going to capture your knight and
even if white does some tricky moves
here to maybe get the black king in the
open Rook F3 check King D7 you will play
king queen captures on C4 but now King
to D6 and the king is very safe here you
have a knight and Rook look for a queen
and also you're up two pawns this is
compensation uh definitely compensation
in itself uh but it was not played in
the game after Bishop to G5 that's why I
said this Knight to C3 move was stronger
as Duda had this option but Duda played
Queen to B4 he attacked The Rook here
but now Alexander just plays a rook to
E2 we have Pawn to G6 uh preparing Pawn
to H5 and now D that Alexander even
forces it Queen to H4 going for H7 we
have Pawn to H5 and queen back to G3
and now the big problem here is that
although you would love to defend your
G6 Pawn with something like Bishop to E8
then comes B3 and uh now the Knight has
to move and The Rook on E5 will hang so
you can't really allow that so Queen
captur on B2 was played but now you have
to give up something else Knight to F6
with check and now if you capture the
Knight that's terrible then Bishop
captures attacks The Rook The Rook
cannot move because the queen is on B2
also Queen captures and G6 is coming and
the black is just getting checkmated
here so he tried King to G7 and now
comes Knight captures on H5 with check
and of course the the pawn cannot the
Knight cannot be captured if you capture
uh uh as it did happen in the game the
game ends really quickly uh so feel free
to pause the video for the final time
and win the game for Alexander PRK it's
actually mate in three so while I give
you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations I'm always looking
for the cleanest and quickest way to
Checkmate the opponent's king and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Bishop I'm only kidding it is
Bishop to H6 this is what Alexander
played and now of course if you capture
then it's just Queen to G6 Checkmate
let's not forget about our good friend
the light Square Bishop on C2 uh so he
went King to F7 but now comes Queen to
G7 with check and he was in this
position on move 31 that Yang shishto
Duda resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here one more
move can be played is the only Square
King d8 and then Queen f8 will result in
Checkmate so very very big win by
Alexander pret and um uh yeah if you
guys are interested in some of the
pairings from round three uh on board
one Fabiano corano will be facing Irvin
Lami uh who is playing an incredible
tournament so far defeated vid guati in
round one and Vladimir fedos in round
two so I mean absolutely incredible
erigi will be facing Alexis Sana Yip
Peno will be facing Alexander prka the
winner of this wonderful round ala fuja
will be facing an international Master J
makov Jean makov from Kazakhstan then we
have Anish giri versus aan bakro rort
versus volokitin cindo versus Aran
chaparo yongi shirov abdat Naran vugo
and so on and so on
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it nicely taking down one of the
one of the well potential winners of the
tournament even Yang Shish Duda as he is
such a such a strong and amazing player
big congratulations to Alexander prka
and especially uh to such a game and
this is what I say even though everyone
knows it's like uh uh you know that such
moves don't uh necessarily work by force
and it's even sometimes easy to defend
against them you can see how it can also
be very very
difficult even a move like Pawn to G4
here I mean completely busting open
Black's position and uh it's just very
hard chess is just very hard there you
have it so once again really hope you
enjoyed it uh I would like to thank
Daniel Taylor marba krii grid words
logical letters for iOS John gear law
office and Mario Milano for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and also covering
the Fay Grand Swiss uh until it finishes
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day